okay today I'm going to talk to you
about fractional distillation so
fractional distillation is a method of
separating the different components of
crude oil in order to get different
fractions which could be used for
different purposes
so essentially crude oil is a big
mixture of different hydrocarbons some
of those hydrocarbons are long so they
have a long chain length some I'm sure
the chain lengths and some are very
short chain lengths so crude oil is a
big mixture of different hydrocarbons
with different chain lengths when
they're all mixed together as crude oil
we can't use these different parts for
their particular purposes we need to
separate them and that's what fractional
distillation is it's separating the
different parts of crude oil based upon
their boiling point so it's using the
different boiling points of these
different chain lengths in order to
separate them the longer the chain
length the higher the boiling point
remember boiling points is the
temperature required in order to turn a
substance from a liquid to a gas so this
is how it works first of all what you do
is you feed the crude oil in to this
particular part here of the fractional
distillation column here is where it
gets heated so a lot of heat energy is
provided and then the oil goes into the
fractional distillation column now the
whole of the fractional distillation
column works because at the bottom it's
hotter and at the top it's cooler and as
you go up the column there's a gradient
in temperature goes from very hot to
much cooler at each level it gets
slightly cooler the further you get up
the further you go up so when you heat
the crude oil the vast majority of the
parts of crude oil turn from a liquid to
a gas so they evaporate and travel up
the column so they go up like this now
at the first
bitumen is one of the fractions of crude
oil made of very long-chain hydrocarbons
so it has a very high boiling point as a
result this doesn't evaporate and it
just comes out of the bottom as a liquid
here bitumen could be used for surfacing
roads and it's made of 70-plus carbon
atoms in the in the hydrocarbon chain so
the rest of the fraction so all of the
other parts of the crude oil all
evaporate and they all go up the column
now here's the clever bit at each
different part of the column we reach
the boiling point of one of the
different fractions so next up we reach
the boiling point of fuel oil so what
happens at this stage here is fuel oil
condenses and it turns from a gas back
into a liquid and it comes out here the
reason why it does that is it's slightly
cooler than the very hot part of the
fractional distillation column at the
bottom so this is where the fuel oil
comes out now fuel oil could be used as
fuel for big ships and it can also be
used it can also be used in certain
power stations as well
now this fuel oil is made of chains
which are 40-plus carbons in the
hydrocarbon sequence now remember at
this temperature here it's still pretty
hot so most of these other fractions are
still in the gaseous state they're still
gasses so they continue to rise up the
column as we get to the next section the
next one condenses because it's that
little bit cooler so at this stage we
have diesel oil which condenses now
diesel oil can be used basically for in
fuel for some cars and larger vehicles
as well so I'm just drawing a quick
simple diagram of a lorry right here to
show that
so again we get the idea that at
different stages these different
fractions condense and come out we can
then use the fraction for their specific
jobs so diesel is basically can
hydrocarbon change which around 20
carbons in the chain so we've just got
three more fractions to look at again at
this stage these fractions because
they've got a shorter chain length they
are still in the steel gases they have
not condensed yet so they keep going up
at this level here we have the next
fraction which is called kerosene so
they're hydrocarbons which are similar
it have similar boiling points and they
have around 15 carbons in the chain and
we could use this one use kerosene
basically as jet fuel so fuel for for
aeroplanes so that there is kerosene so
we've got two more fractions to go so
next up we reach the boiling point of
petrol and petrol condenses at this
stage here now petrol could be used for
fuel for cars obviously so that's the
worst car I've ever drawn but this the
length of petrol is about eight carbons
in the chain and finally the gases that
go up out of the top and they don't even
condense they just stay in the in as
gases if really short
hydrocarbon chain length is LPG now LPG
can be used for domestic heating and
cooking so they basically stay in the
gaseous form and come straight at the
top of the fractional distillation
column now these are around three
carbons in length in the insert in terms
of the chain so to summarize fractional
distillation is a way of separating all
the different hydrocarbons in
Doyle it depends on the different
boiling points the longer the chain
length the lower out of the fractional
distillation column it will come due to
them having a higher boiling point and
these are all of the different uses of
all of the different fractions thank you